we not only see she as a bride but she's  eight months pregnant  interior wedding chapel day overhead  shot  we hear step step step  to the man we haven't seen yet in just a  shot right next to the Fallen bride he  lowers down next to her on his haunches  holding a white handkerchief with the  name Bill sewn in the corner and begins  tenderly wiping away the blood from the  young bride's face while still in her  close-up the bride speaks for the first  time in the picture she looks up at the  man standing over her and says villager  baby  a beat after she says the word baby  we hear a bang and the bride receives a  bullet inside of earth cut to black  screen before film I quit insurance  [Laughter]